let's say i have the vector valued
function r
of s
and t
is equal to x is going to be a function
of s and t so we'll just write it as x
of s and t
times the x unit vector or i
plus
y of s and t times the y unit vector or
j
plus z of s and t times the z unit
vector k
so given that we have this vector-valued
function let's define or let's think
about what it means to take the partial
derivative of this vector-valued
function with respect to one of the
parameters s or t i think it's going to
be pretty natural nothing completely
bizarre here we've taken partial
derivatives of non-vector-valued
functions before where we
only vary one of the variables we only
take it with respect to one variable you
hold the other one constant we're going
to do the exact same thing here and
we've taken regular derivatives of
vector-valued functions the path and
those just ended up being the regular
derivative of each of the terms we're
going to see it's going to be the same
thing here with the partial derivative
so let's define
the partial derivative
the partial derivative of r
with respect to s and everything i do
with respect to s you could just swap it
with t and you're going to get the same
exact result i'm going to define it as
being equal to the limit
the limit as
delta s
approaches zero
of
r of
s plus delta s we're only finding the
limit with respect to a change in s
comma t we're holding t you can imagine
constant for given t
minus
r of
s
and t
all of that over
all of that over delta
s
now if you do a little bit of algebra
here you literally you know r of s plus
delta s comma t that's the same thing as
x of s plus delta s t i
plus y of s plus delta s t j plus c all
of that minus this thing if you do a
little bit of algebra with that and if
you don't believe me try it out this is
going to be equal to
this is all going to be equal to let me
write here it's going to be equal to the
limit of delta s approaching 0 and i'm
going to write it small because i take
up a lot of space of
x of s plus
delta s
comma t minus x of
minus x of s and t i think you know
where i'm going this is all a little bit
monotonous to write it all out but
never hurts
times s or divided by delta s times i
and then i'll do it in different colors
so it's less monotonous plus
y where every those limit as delta s
approaches 0 applies to every term i'm
writing out here
y of s plus delta s
comma t
minus y of s comma t all of that over
delta s
times j
and then finally
plus
z of s plus delta s
comma t minus z of s and t all of that
over
delta s
times the z unit vector k and this all
comes out of this definition if you
literally just put s plus delta s in
place for s you evaluate all this to a
little algebra you're going to get this
exact same thing and this hopefully
makes pops out at usg we're just taking
the partial derivative of each of these
functions with respect to s and these
functions right here
this x of s and t this is a non-vector
valued function this y this is also a
non-vector valued function z is also a
non-vector valued function when you put
them all together
it becomes a vector function because
we're multiplying the first one times a
vector the second one times another
vector the third one times another
vector but independently these functions
are non-vector valued so this is just
the definition of the regular partial
derivatives we're taking the limit as
delta s approaches zero in each of these
cases so this is the exact same thing
this is equal to this is the exact same
thing as the partial derivative of
x with respect to s
times
i plus
the partial derivative of y with respect
to s
times j
plus
the partial derivative of z with respect
to s
times
k
i'm going to do one more thing here and
this is pseudomathy but it's going to
come out the whole reason i'm doing even
doing this video is it's going to give
give us some good tools or in our
toolkit for the videos that i'm about to
do on surface integrals
so i'm going to do one thing here that's
a little pseudo mathy and that's really
because differentials are these things
that are very hard to define rigorously
but i think it'll give you the intuition
of what's going on
so this thing right here i'm going to
say this is also equal to and you're not
going to see this in any math textbook
and hardcore mathematicians are going to
kind of cringe when they see me do this
but i like to do it because i think
it'll give you the intuition on what's
going on when we take our surface
integrals so i'm going to say that this
whole thing right here
this whole thing right here that that is
equal to
that that is equal to
r
of s plus the differential of s a super
small change in s
t
minus r
of s and t
all of that over
that same smooth super small change in s
so hopefully you understand at least why
i view things this way when i take the
limit as delta s approaches zero these
delta s's are going to get super duper
duper small and in my head that's how i
imagine differentials when someone says
when someone writes d the the derivative
of y with respect to x and let's say
that they you know and let's say that
they say that is two and we've done a
little bit of math with differentials
before mult you can imagine multiplying
both sides by
the dx and you could get d y is equal to
two dx we've done this throughout
calculus what the way i imagine is super
small change in y infinitely small
change in y is equal to two times the
you can imagine an equally small change
in x so it's a well that
if you have a super small change in x
your change in y is going to be still
super small but it's going to be two
times that i guess that's the best way
to view it but in general i view
differentials as super small changes in
a variable
so that out of the way and me explaining
to you that many mathematicians would
cringe at what i just wrote hopefully
this gives you a little you know this
doesn't this isn't like some crazy thing
i did i'm just saying oh delta s as
delta approaches 0. i kind of imagine
that as ds and the whole reason i did
that is if you take this side and that
side and multiply both sides times this
differential ds
then what happens
the left side the left hand side you get
the partial of r
with respect to s
is equal to this oh let me times d s
i'll do ds and maybe pink times ds this
is just a regular differential super
small change in s this was a kind of a
partial with respect to s
that's going to be equal to
that's going to be equal to well if you
multiply this side of the equation times
ds this guy is going to disappear so
it's going to be
r of s plus our super small change in s
t
minus r
of s and t and let me put a little
square around this this is going to be
valuable for us in the next video we're
going to actually think about what this
means and how to visualize this on a
surface as you can imagine this is a
vector right here right you have two
vector valued functions you're taking
the difference and we're going to
visualize it in the next video it's
going to really help us with surface
integrals by the same exact logic we can
do everything we did here with s we can
do it with t as well so we can define
we can define the partial i'll draw a
little well i can define the partial of
r
with respect let me do it in a different
color completely different color
it's orange the partial of r with
respect to t
the definition is just right here the
limit
as delta t approaches 0
of r of
s
t plus delta t
minus r of s and t in this situation
we're holding the s you can imagine it
constant we're finding its change in
t
all of that over
delta t and the same thing falls out
this is equal to the partial of x with
respect to t i plus y with respect to t
j plus z with respect to t k same exact
thing you just kind of swap the s's and
the t's
and by that same logic you'd have the
same result but in terms of t if you do
this pseudo mathy thing that i did up
here and you would get the partial of r
with respect to t
times a super small change in t d t our
t differential you could imagine is
equal to r
of
s
t plus d t
minus r of s
and t so let's box these two guys away
and in the next video we're gonna
actually visualize what these mean
and sometimes when you kind of do a
bunch of like silly math like this
you're always like all right whatever
it's all about remember all i did is i
say what does it mean to take the
derivative of this with respect to s or
t played around with it a little bit i
got this result this is going to be
these two are going to be very valuable
for us i think in getting the intuition
for why surface integrals look the way
they do